IT WILL TAKE THE FULL HOUR.
WE START WITH OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
LET'S SEND A MONTH AGO, MASSIVE
CATEGORY FOUR HURRICANE MADE
LANDFALL ON THE GULF COAST OF
FLORIDA, 35 COUNTIES WERE UNDER
EMERGENCY PER 150-MILE-PER-HOUR
WINDS WREAKING HAVOC THROUGHOUT
THE PANHANDLE.
THE DESTRUCTION, AS YOU CAN SEE,
AS WE SAW, WAS HORRIFIC.
ENTIRE BLOGS WERE LITERALLY
WIPED AWAY.
THE AREA SUSTAINED BILLIONS IN
DAMAGE.
FLORIDIANS IN THE PANHANDLE WENT
TO THE POLLS AND THEIR VOTES
WERE COUNTED.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM ON TIME
IN ACCORDANCE WITH FLORIDA LAW
AND FLORIDA'S CONSTITUTION.
SADLY, THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
IN SOUTHERN FLORIDA.
AND PALM BEACH,
BROWARD COUNTY'S, WE ARE
WITNESSING A COLOSSAL DISASTER.
LAWS HAVE BEEN BROKEN.
FLORIDA'S CONSTITUTION IGNORED.
NONE OF THIS CAUSED BY A
HURRICANE, BUT RATHER LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHO ARE INCOMPETENT,
CORRUPT, AND OBVIOUSLY FEEL THEY
ARE ABOVE THE LAW, THAT 65 OTHER
FLORIDA COUNTIES, THEY ADHERED
TO.
IN PALM BEACH COUNTY.
15,000 NEW BALLOTS WHERE ON AND
COUNTED AFTER ELECTION NIGHT.
IN BROWARD COUNTY, ALMOST 75,000
SO-CALLED "UNCOUNTED VOTES"
MAGICALLY TURNING UP DAY AFTER
DAY AFTER DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
TENS AND THOUSANDS OF LOST
BALLOTS JUST SEEMINGLY APPEARED
OUT OF THIN AIR!
THE VAST MAJORITY, OF COURSE, --
THEY SHOULD NOT, LET ME BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE
REPUBLICAN/DEMOCRAT,
CONSERVATIVE/LIBERAL.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE ABOUT
POLITICS.
THIS IS MUCH DEEPER.
WHATEVER YOUR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION, WHAT WE ARE
WITNESSING IS A HORRIFIC
MISCARRIAGE OF AMERICA'S MOST
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
AND IN A SERIOUS POTENTIAL, NO
CRIMINAL VIOLATION.
THE LAW IS CLEAR.
IT IS UNAMBIGUOUS.
FLORIDA LAW: LET'S PUT IT ON THE
SCREEN.
"THAT CANVASSING BOARD SHALL
REPORT ALL EARLY VOTING, ALL
TABULATED VOTE BY MAIL RESULTS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
WITHIN 30 MINUTES AFTER THE
POLLS CLOSE."
THE LAW CONTINUES.
"THE CANVASSING BOARD SHALL
REPORT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
PROVISIONAL BALLOT RESULTS
UPDATED PRECINCT ELECTION
RESULTS TO THE DEPARTMENT AT
LEAST EVERY 45 MINUTES UNTIL
RESULTS ARE COMPLETELY
REPORTED."
65 OF FLORIDA'S 67 COUNTIES,
THEY COMPLIED WITH THE LAW,
INCLUDING EVERY COUNTY IN THE
PANHANDLE THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY
RAVAGED BY HURRICANE MICHAEL 27
DAYS PRIOR TO THE ELECTION.
BROWARD, PALM BEACH COUNTY,
TOTALLY IGNORED THE LAW.
BROKE THE LAW.
FOUR DAYS, BROWARD COUNTY
OFFICIALS CONTINUED TO TALLY
LITERALLY TENS AND THOUSANDS OF
VOTES IN VIOLATION OF STATE LAW.
IT APPEARS YET AGAIN WE HAVE ONE
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE AND ELECTIONS
FOR DEMOCRATS AND ANOTHER FOR
THE REST OF US.
THE SUPERVISOR OF ELECTIONS IN
BROWARD COUNTY, A WOMAN BY THE
NAME OF BRENDA SNIPES, WOULD NOT
EVEN TELL STATE OFFICIALS WHERE
THESE MYSTERIOUS VOTES WERE
COMING FROM.
WHERE THE VOTES HAVE BEEN.
HOW MANY VOTES WERE LEFT TO BE
COUNTED.
AGAIN, A VIOLATION OF LAW.
THERE WAS NO UPDATING OF VOTES
EVERY 45 MINUTES.
AGAIN, VIOLATING THE LAW.
THIS MORNING, MULTIPLE BOXES
FULL OF SAMPLE AND PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS LEFT BEHIND IN SOME
RENTAL CAR, WERE ACTUALLY
DISCOVERED BY AN AVIS EMPLOYEE
AT FORT LAUDERDALE AIRPORT.
THIS IS INSANITY.
WE SEND ELECTION OBSERVERS TO
OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE NEED THEM HERE.
ON FRIDAY, FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
MATT GATE LITERALLY BLOCKED FROM
OBSERVING A LOCATION WHERE
BALLOTS WERE BEING LOADED INTO A
TRUCK.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> WHY CAN'T WE WATCH WHAT'S
GOING ON, MAN?
>> YOU CAN'T BE HERE.
>> WHO TOLD YOU WE CAN'T WATCH
WHAT'S GOING OFF THE TRUCK?
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
YOU TELL ME WHY WE CAN'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING IN AND OUT OF THAT
TRUCK.
WHAT'S THE NAME OF YOUR
SUPERVISOR?
>> WILL GET ALL THIS TAKEN CARE
OF.
DO YOU KNOW THEIR NAME?
THE SUPERVISOR'S NAME WHAT IS
THEIR NAME?
YOU KNOW THEIR NAMES?
WILL YOU TELL IT TO ME?
>> WHAT'S ON THE TRUCK
>> Sean: WE ARE SEEING IN
SOUTH FLORIDA IS A NATIONAL
DISGRACE AND IT'S MUCH MORE THAN
THAT.
PALM BEACH PALM BEACH COUNTY
VIOLATED ANY CHANCE OF THERE BEI
VIOLATED ANY CHANCE OF THERE BEG
ANY REAL INTEGRITY IN THE VOTE I
ANY REAL INTEGRITY IN THE VOTE N
FLORIDA.
WE WILL NEVER HAVE ANY CHANCE OF
KNOWING WHAT THE ACCURATE VOTE
TALLIES WERE FROM THIS PAST
ELECTION IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THAT HAS BEEN RULED.
THAT'S OFF THE TABLE.
TONIGHT, ALL WE REALLY KNOW FOR
CERTAIN IS THAT THE "NEWLY
COUNTED BALLOTS" HAVE
DRASTICALLY TIGHTENED THE
ELECTION AND SUBSEQUENTLY
TRIGGERING STATEWIDE RECOUNTS.
ALL BECAUSE OF WHAT IS GROSS
INCOMPETENCE, CORRUPTION, AT THE
BROWARD COUNTY SUPERVISOR OF
ELECTION BOARD AND BRENDA
SNIPES.
SHE HAS A HISTORY OF THIS.
LATE LAST WEEK, WE HAVE A JUDGE
RULING THAT BRENDA SNIPES
ACTUALLY VIOLATED STATE ELECTION
LAW.
WHAT IS MORE OUTRAGEOUS IS THIS
IS NOT NEW FOR MS.   SNIPES.
HER TRACK RECORD IS LITERALLY
ATROCIOUS.
WHY SHE'S IN THIS POSITION IS
BEYOND ANY UNDERSTANDING.
HOW SHE'S BEEN ALLOWED TO BE IN
THIS POWERFUL POSITION IS BEYOND
COMPREHENSION.
WE LEARNED THAT SNIPES
"ACCIDENTALLY MIXED IN
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS WITH SEVERAL
HUNDRED VALID VOTES.
THAT MEANS THE ENTIRE VOTE COUNT
HAS BEEN IRREVERSIBLE CORRUPTED.
THIS PAST AUGUST, A JUDGE RULED
THAT SNIPES MISHANDLED MAIL-IN
BALLOTS.
A JUDGE ALSO RULED SHE ILLEGALLY
DESTROYED BALLOTS FOLLOWING A
PRIMARY RACE, AND IN 2016, SOME
BROWARD COUNTY ELECTION RESULTS
POSTED ONLINE, GET THIS, BEFORE
THE POLLS HAVE CLOSED.
IN 2012, 1,000 ABSENTEE BALLOTS
WERE DISCOVERED IN
BROWARD COUNTY A WEEK AFTER THAT
ELECTION.
IN 2004, THEY LOST TRACK OF
16,000 ABSENTEE BALLOTS FOR THIS
IS THE WOMAN WHO CAN DETERMINE
THE OUTCOME OF THESE IMPORTANT
RACES FOR THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE IN FLORIDA.
FLORIDIANS ARE CALLING FOR CUTS
ONCE IS, FORMER GOVERNOR JEB
BUSH TWEETING OUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THE BROWARD COUNTY
OF ELECTION SUPERVISOR BRENDA
SNIPES FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
FLORIDA LAW ON MULTIPLE COUNTS
UNDERMINING FLIRTY AND THE
POSITIVE HE HAS CONFIDENCE
ELECTORAL
-- SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM HER
OFFICE FOLLOWING THE RECOUNTS.
MAYBE NOW?
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD WAIT.
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO, VERY VOCAL,
ALSO ABOUT SNIPES AND HER
INCOMPETENCE AND CORRUPTION,
EVERY VOTE TIME FRAME REQUIRED
BY LAW SHOULD BE COUNTED.
THE ISSUE IN FLORIDA HAS BEEN
CONTINUED VIOLATIONS BY THE
INCOMPETENCE AND LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY OF PALM BEACH
ELECTIONS.
BROWARD COUNTY ELECTIONS.
AND NOW SNIPES COULD IN FACT
TONIGHT BE FACING CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
SOURCES HAVE CONFIRMED TO US ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS TONIGHT A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
ELECTION MISCONDUCT IN
SOUTH FLORIDA IS NOW ONGOING.
JUST A SHORT TIME AGO, FLORIDA
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM BONDI
RELEASED A LETTER FROM THE
FLORIDA DEPARTMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT STATING THAT THEY
WILL WORK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ON ANY
INVESTIGATION AND SUCH ACUTE
PROSECUTION OF BRENDA SNIPES OR
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY HAVE COMMITT
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY HAVE COMMITD
VOTER FRAUD.
THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
TURNED SENATOR ELECT RICK SCOTT
IS SOUNDING THE ROUND DAMMING
ALARM.
YOU DO NOT FIND 93,000 VOTES
UNLESS YOU NEED SMOKE FOR COVER.
THIS IS WHY IT'S SO PROBLEMATIC.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BILL NELSON IS CLEARLY A SORE
LOSER.
HE CANNOT STAND THE FACT THAT
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE ELECTED
FOR, WHAT, THE FIRST TIME IN
DECADES, AND HE'S JUST HERE TO
STEAL THE ELECTION.
HIS LAWYER CAME DOWN HERE AND
SAID TO WIN THE ELECTION.
I'M NOT HERE TO GET A FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION TO MAKE SURE VOTES
ARE NOT COUNTED.
HE WANTS TO WIN BACK THE
ELECTION.
THAT'S HIS ONLY PURPOSE.
>> Sean: MAKE NO MISTAKE, WHEN
THE DUST SETTLES HERE, RICK
SCOTT AND RON DeSANTIS WILL
TAKE THEIR RIGHTFUL PLACE AS
SENATOR AND GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
TONIGHT, DEMOCRATIC OPERATIVES
ARE TRYING TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
ON FRIDAY, LAWYERS FOR THE
GILLUM AND NELSON CAMPAIGN, THEY
ACTUALLY OBJECTED TO A JUDGE,
AND NONCITIZENS VOTES BEING
RIGHTFULLY DENIED!
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WANT VOTES
FROM NONCITIZENS TO NOW VOTE.
WHERE IS THEIR INTEGRITY IN ALL
OF THIS TONIGHT?
THAT MEANS THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT
POWER.
NOTHING ELSE.
RULE OF LAW MEANS NOTHING TO
THEM.
IT GETS EVEN WORSE.
NELSON JUST HIRED AN ATTORNEY.
HIS NAME IS MARK LES.
HIS NAME MAY SOUND FAMILIAR TO
YOU.
HE'S THE LEFT-WING HACK AT THE
VERY CENTER OF HILLARY CLINTON'S
ATTEMPT TO RIG THE 2016 ELECTION
WITH THAT PHONY DOSSIER.
REMEMBER, THE DNC PAID MILLIONS
TO DIG UP THE RUSSIAN DIRT,
HIGHER FUSION GPS, HIRING AN
EX-FOREIGN SPY SUBSEQUENTLY PUT
TOGETHER A DIRTY DOSSIER FULL OF
RUSSIAN LIES THAT NOT EVEN
CHRISTOPHER STEELE STOOD BY?
THAT CAMPAIGN OPPOSITION
RESEARCH?
IT WAS DISTRIBUTED ACROSS ALL OF
OBAMA'S DOJ BY STEELE AS
NONPARTISAN, LEAKED TO THE PRESS
BEFORE THE AMERICAN -- 2016,
ONLY DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
HE REPORTED "A VETERAN SPY HAS
GIVEN FBI INFORMATION ALLEGING A
RUSSIAN OPERATIVE TO CULTIVATE
DONALD TRUMP."
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT MICHAEL
AS A COP'S YAHOO REPORT
SEPTEMBER 2016 ALLEGING RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO RIG THE
ELECTION WITH THE HELP OF
HILLARY IS BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
FOREIGN NATIONALS USING RUSSIAN
LIES.
REMEMBER, NONE OF IT WAS EVER
CONFIRMED.
MOST OF IT HAS BEEN DEBUNKED.
AS YOU CAN SEE, ELIAS HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN RECOUNTS.
IN 2013, THOSE WHO HAVE SEEN
PAST RECOUNTS IN VIRGINIA KNOW
THAT THEY DO NOT TEND TO CHANGE
THE RESULTS.
BY THE WAY, IT WAS ONLY 167 VOTE
ADVANTAGE FOR THE GUY HE IS
REPRESENTING.
THE NEXT YEAR, HE SAID, QUOTE,
RECOUNTS REALLY ONLY HAPPENED
WHERE YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
DOZENS OR A FEW HUNDRED VOTES
SEPARATING CANDIDATES.
GEE, MARC, I WONDER WHY THE
CHANGE OF HEART.
GUNS FOR HIRE, SAY ANYTHING,
JUST MAKE THE RULES UP AS YOU GO
ALONG?
OF COURSE, THE DEMOCRATS PRETTY
MUCH WROTE THE BOOK ON ELECTION
RIGGING DURING THE 2016
ELECTION.
I SEEM LIKE THE ONLY ONE WHO HAS
POINTED THIS OUT.
WE ALL KNOW THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY, WE KNOW IT WAS FIXED
FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
REMEMBER, FORMER INTERIM DNC
CHAIR DONNA BRAZILE ADMITTING
THIS ON MY RADIO SHOW --
REMEMBER, SHE HAS ACTUALLY USED
THE WORD "RIG" THAT SHE BACKED
OFF IN THIS INTERVIEW BUT SHE
ADMITTED SHE USED IT.
>> I SAID IN MY BOOK AND
EXCHANGE FOR BAILING OUT THE
PARTY -- WHICH WAS BROKE, THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN WOULD GET
CONTROL OVER CERTAIN DECISIONS
AND ASPECTS THAT MADE IT
DIFFICULT, IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE,
FOR ME TO DO MY JOB.
IT WAS UNETHICAL, BUT IT WAS NOT
RIGGED.
AND I STAND BY THAT.
>> YOU SAID YOU USE THE WORD
RIG.
>> OF COURSE.
I PROMISED BERNIE THAT I WOULD
GO DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT AND
DO A FORENSIC TEST TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Sean: SHE USED THE WORD
"RIGGED" HERSELF AND SHE TELLS
THE STORY HOW BERNIE WAS ROBBED
BY THE DNC MACHINE THAT CLINTON
WAS CONTROLLING, THE CANCER, AS
SHE CALLED IT.
HANGS UP THE PHONE AFTER HAVING
TELLS BERNIE SANDERS THE TRUTH,
SAID SHE CRIED OUT OF ANGER OVER
THIS.
WE HAVE ONE SYSTEM FOR THIS, AND
ELECTIONS FOR DEMOCRATS BUT LIKE
WE HAVE ONE SYSTEM FOR JUSTICE
FOR THE CLINTONS.
AND ANOTHER ONE FOR ANYONE WHO
OPPOSES THEM.
THIS IS NOT EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW OR EQUAL APPLICATION OF
OUR LAWS.
TONIGHT WE ARE GOING TO BRING
YOU UPDATES ALL THROUGHOUT THE
HOUR FROM FLORIDA AS THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE, BUT A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION -- LET ME REPEAT,
ONGOING AS WE SPEAK.
WHATEVER HAPPENS IN FLORIDA,
THERE IS ONE THING.
I KNOW THE DEMOCRATS WERE ALL
EXCITED BECAUSE THEY GOT CONTROL
OF THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT IN
RETROSPECT, NOW THAT HE WENT OUT
AND FOUGHT FOR ALL THOSE SENATE
CANDIDATES AND REPUBLICANS
PICKED UP THOSE SEATS IN THE
SENATE, BY THE WAY, TURNED THE
BLUE WAVE INTO A LITTLE BABY
BLUE TRICKLE, IT IS NOW
DEMOCRATS DOING EXACTLY WHAT I
TOLD YOU THEY WOULD DO.
NOW COMING CLEAN SOME OF THE
THINGS THEY WERE SAYING ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, ABOUT WHAT THEIR
REAL PLAN IS TO WAGE WHAT IS A
NEVER ENDING FULL-SCALE
INVESTIGATION INTO ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING DONALD TRUMP TO
DESTROY THIS PRESIDENT,
ACCORDING TO NEW REPORTS, PELOSI
AND COMPANY -- GET THIS.
THEY ARE PLANNING TO LAUNCH A
SUBPOENA CAN CANNON WITH A POLIT
SUBPOENA CAN CANNON WITH A POLIC
SUBPOENA CAN CANNON WITH A POLIL
HIT LIST OF NEARLY 100 TARGETS,
MEANING 100 INVESTIGATIONS.
TAX RETURNS, STORMY DANIELS,
JAMES COMEY, IMPEACHMENTS OF
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, WANTS TO
INVESTIGATE THE TREATMENT OF
"WASHINGTON POST," AMAZON.
DEMOCRATS ARE STOPPING AT
NOTHING TO PURSUE THE UNHINGED
CAMPAIGN TO HALT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS PROGRESS.
BY THE WAY, THAT MEANS OUR
PROGRESS FOR THAT MEANS
AMERICA'S PROGRESS.
OF COURSE, THIS IS A PLAN OF
ENDLESS INVESTIGATIONS.
BY THE WAY, VERY FEW FACTS.
NANCY PELOSI ACTUALLY SAYING
DEMOCRATS DON'T NEED AN
INDICTMENT TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THEIR IMPEACHMENT FANTASIES
WHILE SHE AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
FEEL EVEN MORE BASELESS HYSTERIA
ABOUT MUELLER'S RUSSIA PROBE.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING OVER DRIVE TO NOW SMEAR
THE ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
WOULD OCCUR WHICH WAS THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWFUL CHOICE PERIO
PERIOD.
DON'T FORGET ROD ROSENSTEIN
WHO'S BEEN RUNNING THIS WHOLE
THING CONFLICTING IN MULTIPLE
WAYS LIKE SIGNING A FI
FISA, BUT
THEY ARE STILL RUNNING IT, THEY
DON'T CARE ABOUT HIS CONFLICTS.
>> I WANT TO MAKE THIS VERY
CLEAR, IF HE DOESN'T RECUSE
HIMSELF, IF HE HAS ANY
INVOLVEMENT WHATSOEVER IN THIS
RUSSIA PROBE, WE ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT IF YOU MADE COMMITMENTS
TO THE PRESIDENT ABOUT THE
PROBLEM OF SERVING AS A BACK
CHANNEL TO THE PRESIDENT OR THE
LAWYERS ABOUT HIS PROBE, WHETHER
HE'S DOING ANYTHING TO INTERFERE
WITH THE PROBE, MR. WHITAKER
NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND HE'LL BE
CALLED TO UNDERSTAND AND ANY
ROLE HE PLAYS WILL BE EXPOSED TO
THE PUBLIC.
WE DO NOT WANT THERE TO BE ANY
AMBIGUITY ABOUT THAT.
>> YOU DO NOT HAVE ANY
CONFIDENCE IN HIM?
>> NO, I DON'T.
DON'T TAKE IT FROM ME.
THERE IS BIPARTISAN
EDITORIALIZING ABOUT THIS THAT
HE SHOULD'VE NEVER BEEN
APPOINTED AND IT DOES VIOLENCE
TO THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
MISSION OF OUR FOUNDERS TO
APPOINT SUCH A PERSON IN SUCH A
MATTER TO BE THE CHIEF LEGAL
OFFICE OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S BIPARTISAN.
>> I WILL GO FURTHER.
HIS APPOINTMENT IS SIMPLY PART
OF AN ATTACK ON THE
INVESTIGATION BY ROBERT MUELLER,
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT'S PART OF A PATTERN OF
INTERFERENCE BY THE PRESIDENT ON
THE PART OF PATTERN OF
OBSTRUCTION.
>> Sean: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT MEDDLING
WITH THE MUELLER PROBE.
NOBODY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD TWICE IN
THE LAST WEEK, NO.
ASK YOURSELF, THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS -- IS THERE A SINGLE
AGENDA ITEM THAT THEY ARE
ADVOCATING THAT WILL MAKE YOUR
LIFE BETTER?
ANYONE AGENDA ITEM THAT WILL
CREATE MORE JOBS, MAKE THIS
COUNTRY SAFER, BUILD A BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR OUR KIDS AND OUR
GRANDKIDS BOOKS MAKE UP WELL, WE
KNOW THE ANSWER TONIGHT IS NO.
IT'S ALL PART OF WHAT I'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU, THEY'VE BEEN HIDING
WHAT THEIR AGENDA IS REALLY ALL
ABOUT.
IT SLIPPED OUT OCCASIONALLY AND
THEY TELL EVERYBODY, STOP, WHICH
IS MORE
MOBILIZING THEIR POLITICAL
HIT LIST.
THEY DID NOT LIKE THE RESULT OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THIS ELECTION.
THEY WANT TO SHIELD THEIR
DEEP STATE CORRUPTION.
WHAT THEY OUGHT TO BE FOCUSED ON
IS OUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS.
AND LAW AND ORDER.
AN EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS.
YES, SOMETHING CALLED OUR